-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
-Very hyped-up crowd tonight.
-Yes, I know why.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
-(LAUGHS)
-(CROWD CHEERING)
-Well... I know it's because...
-(CROWD APPLAUDING)
...we're in Hollywood,
and the actors' strike
is finally over.
-The--
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
For you-- for you
younger people watching,
the-- the actors
are the people in movies
pointing at the CGI...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-...basically.
But, no, I worry.
I mean,
with the actors' strike over,
who's gonna figure out
the Israeli-Palestinian conflict
on Twitter.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-Oh, here's where we are...
-(CHUCKLES)
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
Here's where we are with that,
the Museum of Tolerance,
here in L.A.
-(MAN LAUGHING)
-The Museum of Tolerance.
-(LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
They had a showing-- a movie
about this,
and fist fights broke out.
-(SMACKS LIPS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Fourteen people
were treated for irony.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
At the Museum of Tolerance,
that's where we are.
(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
Well, and they--
they were showing,
43 minutes of the Hamas attack
on October 7th in Israel,
and without
any editorialization,
just the footage
that they themselves,
Hamas, took
and wanted the world to see.
But the pro-Palestinian people
did demonstrate
they do not like this.
The college kids
especially think that the--
Well, they prefer to think
of the Hamas people
as just a kind
of a ragtag bunch of underdogs,
kind of the Bad News Bears
of the Middle East.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
This was a big topic
at the Republican debate
last night.
I don't know
if you saw that, the--
Oh, I guess not.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-I didn't either. I didn't.
I can't lie. I wouldn't.
-Please.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
Well...
they're down to five candidates
on the island now,
-and...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
...all of them,
Trump is beating by 40 points.
The only reason to be in this
is to be there
if Trump
for some reason can't run.
That's the one thing Republicans
and Democrats have in common now
they're both waiting
for their nominees to die.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-(LAUGHS)
But there was a--
It was a good-news-bad-news week
for the Democrats.
Bad news in--
in the six Battleground States.
Trump is beating Biden
in five out of six of them.
And Biden support
among non-White voters
dropped 33 points, and this--
Democrats cannot win
with just White people.
-(SMACKS LIPS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-Oh, oh, oh! (LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
Although,
it hasn't hurt Taylor Swift.